I wanted to create a video that gives
you all the things that can block
nutrients in your body okay and here's
ten of them starting with number one low
stomach acids first of all how do you
know if you have low stomach acids well
do have indigestion heartburn bloating
when you eat GERD you don't have enough
stomach acid as we get older we lose our
stomach acid that's why el pasad vinegar
is very important you're not going to be
able to digest protein that well
especially absorbing amino acids so
that's one thing and minerals minerals
need an acidic stomach to be able to
absorb iron and calcium magnesium so
without an acid stomach you're not going
to pull in minerals and trace minerals
okay so that's one number two low bile
if you don't have a gallbladder if you
have a gallbladder congestion if you
have bloating any issues with your
gallbladder because you don't have
enough file then you're not going to be
able to multiply and break down those
fats and pull them into your body so
you'll be deficient in the fat soluble
vitamins vitamin A for the eyes D E and
K two so you can have problems with any
of those next one number three insulin
resistance I've created a lot of videos
on this because this insulin controls
the absorption of certain nutrients
especially potassium magnesium protein
and other nutrients okay but primarily
potassium and amino acids so you'll have
a hard time absorbing potassium I'm
gonna do a whole video just on that but
that's why diabetics for example are
very low in potassium and high in sodium
it's one of the reasons why they have
high blood pressure but the other thing
is they have a lot of muscle loss and
loss of collagen joint issues
inflammation because they're not pulling
in the amino acids in there so they
don't they're not as strong and then
number four elemental minerals so when
you're taking a supplement and you're
reading the label and it says Krause iam
carbonate that's an element that's like
a rock elements are like rocks so when
you take vitamins that are like rock
based they're not going to absorb nearly
as well as plant-based minerals
okay so definitely if the vitamin is
like a paperweight it's really heavy and
a chance design has calcium carbonate in
it don't recommend it but that would be
very poor absorption all right I'm fine
synthetic vitamins synthetic vitamins
are not the same as natural vitamins
they're not in the same complex and I
even like to take it one step further
than just natural vitamins get it
vitamins as their whole complex as a
food base type vitamin that's what I
recommend now if you're doing some
cleanse or detox you can use synthetic
vitamins and natural are much better but
with the food based ones are even better
especially when you get the synthetic
antioxidants they can create a lot of
problems some of the top-selling
vitamins on the planet are all synthetic
they're really cheap and they kind of go
right through you that's why the urine
is very bright orange and yellow with
the B vitamins because the synthetics
the body's rejecting it okay number six
antibiotics destroy the floor of the
good bacteria so you're gonna have a
hard time assimilating nutrients as well
also your pH and your colon is going to
be altered and you need that that
acidified that acidic large bowel to
uphold insert nutrients and help you
digest so without that you're gonna have
a problem number seven low fat diets fat
Seibel vitamins are in fatty foods so if
you're a little fat you're gonna be
missing vitamin A D E and K okay number
eight vegan diets now it's very
difficult to get certain nutrients if
you're vegan number one b12 an active
form of vitamin A like retinol because
that's mainly in animal products and
vitamin k2 unless you're taking
something called NATO which you can get
k2 and it's a fermented soy product but
recently I did analysis on my wheatgrass
juice powder because I wanted to see the
nutrition in there and I'm looking
through the vitamins and minerals and I
happen to notice something I thought it
was a mistake it should be 12 in
wheatgrass and it was actually double
the RDA it was twice as much as it that
you would even need a
actually shocked I thought there was an
air I called the farm where I grow it
and I says have you ever seen this
before and they said that well naturally
all the grasses and the do not have b12
it's just not in there and that includes
chlorella and some of these other things
but where you're getting it from is the
the friendly bacteria that lives within
the grass I found that fascinating so
the bacteria is making the b12 so that
was really cool so now I have some proof
that there's some b12 and wheatgrass
juice powder okay number nine mineral
oil
don't ever consume in or oil so make
sure like if you're doing some type of
product that has mineral oil don't
consume it because it's it's going to
block vitamin A vitamin D and kind of
wash that out of your liver it's going
to clean it out of your liver and you're
going to end up depleted so be careful
of consuming mineral oil vitamin D a K
and E okay and the last one is heat
anytime you overcook your vegetables
cook it for too long steam it for too
long you're killing off the nutrition
microwaving it you're killing off the
nutrition that's why pasteurization when
you can foods or your pasteurizing
certain things you're killing off the
most of the nutrition in there so you
want to keep it more raw but that's
definitely a factor that can block
nutrients all right thanks for watching
hey you probably already subscribed but
if you haven't press this little button
down below and I will keep you updated